صناديق الاقتراع تبوح باسرارها في اول
انتخابات تشريعيه بعد الاجراءات
الاستثنائيه في البلاد مجلس هيئه
الانتخابات يعلن ان نسبه المشاركه بلغت
11.22% وعن المرور الى دور ثاني من هذه
الانتخابات قبل تركيز البرلمان الجديد
سجلت الهيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات
قيام مليون وخمسه وعشرين الف
1418 ناخب ايامهم بحق التصويت والادلاء
باصواتهم في جميع المكاتب والمراكز بنسبه
اقبال
11.22%
مجلس هيئه الانتخابات اعلن ان الدوره
الثانيه من التشريعيه سيشمل اكثر من 130
دائره انتخابيه مع تسجيل 1750 مخالفه اثرت
على سير الانتخابات الرئيس قيس سعيد رد
على المطالبين بابطال الانتخابات بالقول
ان نسبه المشاركه لا تقاس فقط بالدور
الاول بل بالدورتين معا معتبرا ان هذا
الموقف صادر عن جهات لا داب لها الا
التشكيك ليتواصل الجدل سياسيا وقانونيا
على اعتبار اهميه الاستحقاق التشريعيه في
البلاد
النخبه التونسي ذهب على مراحل في البدايه
هناك تصويت قوي بل قوي على الانتخابات ثم
ذهب نحو التصويت العقابي الذي حدث في سنه
2014 ثم 2019 واليوم هو يذهب الى مقاطعه
هذه الانتخابات نعم وحوار وطني مره هذا
لاسس في التلامي صحيحه يهم الجانب
الاقتصادي والاجتماعي ثم نتفهم ولا
القاعده السياسيه الجديده واللعبه
السياسيه جديده منها القانون الانتخابي
لنجم يكون على الافراد ولكن يتغير
وستهعلن النتائج النهائيه للانتخابات
التشريعيه في التاسعه عشر من شهر جانفي
كانون الثاني القادم بعد حسم مساله تطيعون
قضائيا واجراء الدور الثاني بدايه شهر في
افريقيا مع الاعلان عن نتائج الاوليه
للانتخابات التشريعه يؤجل الحسم في تركيز
البرلمان الجديد الى دوره ثانيه في ذلك
سياسيا وقانونيا رافق العمليه خاصه وانها
اخر المحطات في مشروع الرئيس سعيد لانهاء
الفتره الاستثنائيه
وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس